I'm unsure if this vlog is even going to
make any sense basically all of the
clips that I've collected throughout e3
now I'm heading over to the Nintendo
booth where I'm going to get some game
captured of Mario Odyssey and I cannot
wait there booth looks so cool let's
take a look what job don't make fun of
you all right guys we're about to play
Mario Odyssey I'm so excited I got a
camp slave another day today the show
floor looks exactly like this new doll
city here's our mayor I'm gonna give us
some tax here's a little odd
let's go it
change your outfit
put on my Safari outfit
let's go out and do some tasks
so that part matters you can just throw
your hat variable has our mayor in
trouble yeah I'll talk to her right
for now their mainstream
consult a rapist lemon actually become
simply resides I throw my hat at it and
now I am
portable and you can go shopping now
with the pointy collectible world
gasps boy if you
[Music]
Hey
I need to find the mayor I'm going to go
chat with her and she's going to give me
some cash and clarity plays I know what
she wants to do he wants me to find
musicians for the town hall and there's
300 large wow wow wow
we're really making you blush control
3 today
getting so close to TVs in here my audio
I go in here put them here
[Music]
my hat's very all right okay well I got
a point I get I get it we're going out
coffee
do not fall off
boy all they need more musicians so I
never actually found all of them so I
only come to you the last time
great I will find you as many as I can
in the moments that I have a lot for
this gameplay they don't work never
where he was like these guys right here
load it start
Julio please pee in my van all right we
got this guy's
well okay UPS would be 31 times clearly
I didn't do it I'm sorry sir sorry sir
can you turn around thank you any one
more great week our bass player now
let's get us a festival this is the
party that I want to be
how much power
great well let's see let me do I got to
throw
okay am i underground it oh we're almost
there
oh wow wow wow okay how are you
oh no my time is blown off this is my
first time walking into the booth and
it's seriously so sweet I played the
game and now I'm here in underdogs
[Music]
and I'm still excited
now we're heading to San Kingdom this
one I'm trying to figure out health on
everything look I didn't get very far
the first time that I played is
like if you're the boys internal one
only good I cleaned up okay I need to
use you to go shopping
like there's so many little things that
you don't even realize that you can do
Hey
Dyson media press it down
I'm having a little
Oh give you
all right this is going to be super cool
so you can basically go from the 3d to
the 2d world like a side-scrolling old
school party game it's
[Music]
oh that's pretty close I never got that
far
[Music]
okay all right this is it
we're gonna finish up the funnel
we're done let's come down here thank
you guys watching enjoyed gameplay let
me know puzzle in here because I'm down
anyway
my feel myself getting up your happy
really yeah I was trying to kill myself
undone play because it's awful alright
well gonna stop light now thanks for
watching I will definitely be doing the
gameplay which game comes out maybe even
livestream I'm not sure alright I'll see
you guys later
now all that
all right you found a new friend now you
tweeted me during WWDC didn't you you
were there on a Gin Gin drought I'm a
blind need uber and gamer as well
because I'm here at e3 kicked everyone's
button platoon as well first place my
channel I do videos about accessibility
and technology and I got a cool stuff
it's pretty awesome
youtube.com slash James Rath drops wr8
eh check it out it's so cool yeah hey
guys sorry alright so I was at e3 press
conference and when we saw you puffle
net screams cartel three trailers people
are going after the booze yes tomorrow
you'll be throwing calm forget dropping
bombs you drop it yeah okay I was going
first of all it's always everybody knows
has always been my dream to be in a
video game to actually be a playable
character in a game you know it was
killing me keeping this secret for a
long long time
and I went in I mean we went to the
studios and I had the sensors all over
me and they were took pictures of our
face and we got the 3d all the cameras
and holding let me tell you I enjoyed
the process I enjoy the game every day
Microsoft did it up you know a lobby
were like okay what about the gameplay
because there was a lot of me and in the
commercial I totally get it
you can't get enough of me okay but but
there will be building being destroyed
there will be lots of destruction lots
of mayhem a lots of cussing which is
good let you started on no no no no
nobody without you believe it all but it
was so intense - so fun
and the mood is just one of you can just
wreck the city and yeah I got away yeah
and so we're here in the caffeine zones
but I've been actually watching you live
streaming on caffeine for like the high
school research more exciting three here
and one of the coolest things all
caffeine is it so actual real time lemon
give them a demo you're going to be
playing okay I'm going to show them my
phone they can see how actual real Simon
is let's do it all right ah 33 through
my let's drink some history all right
Carrie trouble strange mojo you guys
caffeine and I have been working them
for a while now and it's so incredible
because when we talk about zero wait
until new this is going to be absolutely
shocked
anywhere people in the house play there
is no way you cannot name it on your
game
I didn't even know you can do that and
you could like music camera around well
and if you kill it this way I actually
had no idea do that it's so insane oh my
god I love it
well how does it game I can't wait to
play your character I'm so hot
oh my god I'm so excited hey and you
hide 3-3 oh yeah well how hyped are you
ha ha ha ha absolutely I love 4 types
everybody tweet at dotted types just
tweet it it drives me absolutely nuts
and I've been saying it so much - so
he's losing his mind
hi-hi-hi true I'm like oh I bet it's
fairly real I think it's on his way
[Music]
oh I'm so excited I barely get this here
and I love her so much and I'm inside we
have this limpid Cardinal Egan that we
do very clearly God loved it III 2017
let's go
we just said they're going to be 33 and
I'm gonna do so G always like randomly
run at each other somewhere yeah what
has been your favorite thing you seem so
far Super Mario Odyssey if you put the
play agent yes go back over there me -
what are you going back go back later on
today I'm going back and forth you
happen to be there around that around
okay I'll tell you what I'll go ahead at
you yeah then you can become my body
[Laughter]
[Music]
we are here at the call of duty booth
and I'm so excited from abouts headed
and play for the first time hopefully
I'll get some big gameplay for you guys
yeah let that end so if you're wondering
why I'm not saying anything in my
FaceCam
I had all intentions of doing so but the
room that we were capturing in here at
e3 was very very small I also didn't
know any of the other people that were
in the room and of course I wanted to
get rowdy and start yelling and hooting
and hollering but uh you know I just
felt a little uncomfortable so I just
kept quiet and then I was getting really
upset rest of my team wasn't picking it
up but I guess at least it proved for
some good gameplay because I at least
got a bunch of kills both of the other
people in the room I believe were some
journalists not to say the journalists
are not good at call of duty but I had a
lot of fun killing all of them
unfortunately I also had some of them on
my team which proved to be quite
difficult because we were not winning
this team deathmatch at all most of the
people and a lot of my friends that I've
talked to have been so excited and
really really enjoyed playing than your
call of duty and I'm so so happy that
it's fun because I've missed this game
so much I really did not play much of
internet warfare at all to be honest
with you and I think it's pretty obvious
because when I am playing and in love
with something you will see me tweeting
and talking about it making videos
non-stop and it's basically the only
thing that I want to talk about I did
play a bunch of the remastered but for
the most part we've all just kind of
been waiting for this new Call of Duty
World War two here it is as you guys can
see by some of the gameplay we are now
playing team deathmatch there's two
other modes that we also played in this
game the claisen domination and we also
played a new mode called war and the
surprisingly we in fulfilling that I
thought it was going to be and here's
the unfortunate reality of this game we
lost so upset as you could tell by my
FaceCam I'm looking around I'm like
my team who are you and TV guys please
pick it up now we're hopping in twos and
domination here and I guess probably now
was a great time that I should probably
address the fact that you might wonder
quite a lot Jessie where is your gaming
channel and while you post on your
gaming channel anymore and it's a pretty
I guess a very easy answer I just I
don't want to I used to really enjoy
doing Let's Plays and all of those kinds
of things so then it just became work so
playing video games became work to me
and it started not being fun when I
stopped recording and just playing again
I was like this is what I like this is
why I started a gaming channel because I
wanted to share the fun that I was
having playing games but now I think
I've found sort of a happy medium here
on my main channel where I post not as
frequent I was posting like three videos
a day on my gaming channel and that's a
lot of work since I still shoot and edit
everything if I would play games for ten
hours do you know how many hours of
editing that would be it's a lot so for
those of you who do ms my gaming channel
I'm so sorry but I suppose things here
so I hope that you'll understand there's
so many games coming out this year so
you can rest assure there will
definitely be way more gameplay here
than there has been in previous years so
hopefully that's something you guys are
into and if you're not I try to start it
out with something that you might like
like an unboxing we're about to finish
up this match here of domination and I
had I mean I keep talking about I keep
saying that how much fun I had playing
this game and I was really doing
now being through watching the gameplay
I'm getting super hyped not to bring it
back around to the word hype but I am
and let me tell y'all difficult it is
trying
adesh the professionals in miss the
setting like I wanted to start raging
and yelling and freaking out because I
play this game you guys know how I get
so being silent and not saying anything
what's probably the most difficult part
of this so you know what to look forward
to when this game comes out lots of
yelling I'm most excited for destiny too
to be honest with you my sister and I
played that so much when this new one
first came out it looks like we're about
to win this and stay tuned let's look at
this little tiny class that I have to do
because I don't know anybody so I just
played oh my goodness it was so much fun
was it fun yeah that's awesome what was
your favorite part war
I actually surprisingly liked war so
much but it was really really fun so for
them at home who's not have to play it
you want to explain the new game of war
mode is a brand new mode here at e3
where it's a linear and objective mode
where your actress and allies collide
over these strategic points like
building the bridge or protecting the
tank or capturing the manor so bring
squads together in a really powerful way
it's brand new
sounds like you enjoyed it rounded I was
laying in there with the press and I
didn't know anybody and so like I'm like
Yellin and my team editor who was on my
favorite hold
we went pretty crazy in there I was
getting really rowdy like why is nobody
got like back somebody builds a bridge I
know
oh yeah the great thing about war mode
is it really drives through teamwork
right in a way that's new to Call of
Duty it's not the lone wolf anymore it's
not the super soldier it's about your
team so it sounds like you didn't maybe
get on the team like we won we did oh
did we want oh yeah it was so much fun
alright well thank you so much for being
here and congratulations on a credible
game I'm so excited for it I can't
everybody saying Call of Duty's back yes
oh sure that night alone after that game
mode this is called war in our first
mission is to capture this command post
and I'm not a huge fan usually of
playing objective based game I usually
play so much free-for-all when I'm not
playing with my friends or just team
deathmatch or I guess I do like
domination a lot too but I really did
enjoy this game-mode a lot so here we
are capturing this command post and then
you have several other tasks that we
have to complete after this and not
really being able to communicate with
any of my teammates because I didn't
really know who they were definitely
includes to be a little bit difficult
this is one of those games where you do
want to communicate and find out what's
Lorax where our enemies are spawning in
at and there was not a lot of bad it was
also not a lot of coverage here we are
moving over to the next objective which
we are such a constructive bridge and it
is extremely difficult if you're trying
to build this bridge and nobody is
covering you as you guys can see here I
died and all I wanted this build it's
freaking bridge and nobody was getting
my back I'm like hello can somebody else
build a bridge or something if you want
me to cover you I will I'm here for you
the thankfully the build happened and we
moved on to our next objective here
which is to destroy the ammo jump now
this was interesting too and some that
haven't showed you guys yet if you can
build different types of wall so if you
guys have played zombies or any other
types of horde mode games like that you
can prevent enemies from coming into
your different phases so here we go
build master plus 200 points thank you
we all have the bomb planted and now
works escorting the tank what made a
game-mode also really fun is I also have
played on the other side of the tomb
where I was trying to
the tank for being escorted so depending
on which team you are on you're doing
different tasks so here we are objective
complete victory and I just want our
rage and just celebrate but I had no one
to celebrate with my I just played call
of duty it was so much crowd in detail
destroyed that it was so much fun I had
an absolute best time as you may know
before and it's so freakin fun you're
going to love it we're going to have a
great time you met Mike plays later hope
you're get a lot of area love it
absolutely open it okay to play manatee
gonna to know what I won't do I do what
to as well but I just don't think I'm
not trying to play this Oh ridiculously
here screen I know you can have the
whole set of only 75,000
Oh reels are like they get a few real
card
[Music]
don't blow it disease on why I came out
everybody comment first you set it up
girl evilly the attitude of the enemies
here
Eddie free I'm wearing reunited and it
feels so good last time I saw you be
bored doing a Nintendo giveaway radius
acquit on a Southwest like the entire
plane it gave everyone an industry a
this is pretty cool baby run baby run
how are you doing Justine great - ten
dollars being a much and my friend did
half and half so I would like the legs
and he was a hat that was pretty funny
if we got we got legally almost ground
[Music]
I just I would like in someone's way
there as the price goes away to you what
about he is so much fun and good
absolutely crazy I know I know I can't
wait October 27 can't come soon enough
it's on my calendar I mean I haven't
seen you since ages reacting yeah we
didn't even find a weakness in a three
yes on board of airplane it was really
fun thank you for coming by and a load
of us thank you so much winners okay
come on man
he is in charge of it the point
tomorrow's make you I didn't launch and
rolls is I've done it pretty good here
so if you like see you say my name said
he called you princess iJustine yes I
know good day pretty Mario Justine
Bieber was amazing it's so great I
replay that all the time I'm like yeah
my life is made you never know what
you're going to be on video and III show
it's true
oh man explain barriada see it oh and
don't help to Columbus leave Ariane feel
you're probably on your way up slow down
tomorrow's my day tomorrow okay well
Marty tomorrow is your day and I will
play it so
so excited to let me know actually how
are you at art I'm curious I am so back
here
well maybe you should practice a little
yeah I'm deleting all the footage you'll
never see it just a closing in anyway I
was gonna say like work to really clumsy
people exactly and I'm all over the
place the next day I woke up and I pull
up to my arms real powerful real actual
heart also I didn't realize you can
start off the motion control oh well
that's going to be things that is going
to make their weight and also we're good
cufflinks also little standing bass is
what I will definitely do that I'll be
way better
arms off okay that's it III has come to
a close and look it's mr. III himself
how you doing Justin are you how are you
just
I'm good it was it was a long week with
uh you know we had the YouTube show if
you're happy to have you on I was on you
were in a little bit my blog actually
okay yeah you were introducing me and
mad and the rest of my gentleman on
every one of our YouTube channel we had
the e3 Coliseum with the panels were a
lot of fun
you got a shout out from James Gunn I
did I love James he's great
do you guys remember I made him a
birthday cake a couple years ago it was
a group cake here's a clip of that and
that my friends is my really sad attempt
at a group cake happy belated birthday
James pretty great the group cake no he
didn't it was just like a video birthday
cake no gosh you know yeah it was fun
too and I just got to you know check out
some games today I got to play Super
Mario Odyssey yeah I loved it it was
much fun I just wanna drive very little
taxi PP Brett did and I got some Game
Capture of that so is pretty cool for
the for getting that soon on the channel
probably in this video a lovely video
you get to play call duty at all no I
didn't how was it so much fun well
that's it thanks Jeff I'm glad you have
a grade III I had a really fun III I
hope you guys loved all the coverage I'm
you do I think I'm gonna show just game
you're welcome on to the next gaming of
that game awards won the game award
oh yeah the game awards are coming on
Thursday to September 7th
oh boy longer I hope so if I'm not there
I'll be watching online oh well thank
you very much we'll help win every game
word so far so you have come department
I'll be that what is that what is what I
wrote that one register ready all right
guys III 2017 that's it that's a wrap
see you later
[Music]